society makes you hate yourself if you
don't look a certain way and I am damn
determined to change that Jamie Lopez
star of super size salon and founder of
baby doll Beauty Couture has died she
was 37 years old all eyes are on me
there's cameras all over me
[Music]
confirmed her death releasing a
statement to ET on Monday quote on
behalf of the baby doll Beauty Couture
team we regretfully announce with great
pain the passing of the founder and
owner of baby doll Beauty Couture the
legendary Jamie Lopez her team added
that further details will be announced
soon and as the fans give time and space
to Jamie's family and friends to grieve
in peace according to TMZ Jaime died of
heart complications on Sunday after
being admitted to a hospital in Las
Vegas I've literally been designing this
salon for two years and today is finally
the day that my salon is ready I've
worked so hard for this Jamie Rose to
Fame after designing her beauty salon
from bed when she at one point weighed
846 pounds I've decided to make some
drastic changes in my life you guys
but don't nobody come for me okay
because
I have not forgot about my big girls she
documented her 400 pound weight loss
Journey on YouTube and later her we TV
series I'm terrified Shannon I haven't
left the house in two years
and I just learned to walk again
it's a super exciting moment but I'm
terrified to fall it also highlighted
the success of her Salon which catered
to plus-sized women my Glam girls I'm so
happy to see you yeah you guys
supersized Salon premiered on WE tv in
July and was gearing up to film season 2
at the time of Jamie's death
[Music]
foreign
[Music]